25 bands to be on the list to be able to
put your stuff on the table for the
celebrities right and I gave them like
25 pieces of thing and I thought that
was the most detrimental loss of my life
but Public Enemy all wore it no was it
Naughty by Nature I want to say Naughty
by Nature they all were at the BET
Awards my shirt and that's how I got
sued by Tupac's family
[Music]
what up welcome back to the dope as
usual podcast my name is Thomas topazole
what do you even call me I am here with
my co-host Marty O'Neill what's up guys
what's up
what's up guys it's a solo episode okay
we're chilling there's no guests to like
Icebreaker here so we're chilling guys
before we start we never do this if
you're watching wherever you're watching
drop a like leave a like on it leave a
comment if you're on YouTube subscribe
you know hit the notification Bell it's
a little Taco Bell thing right under the
name yeah it looks just like the 90s
Taco Bell logo help us out guys I
appreciate it first off I'm just gonna
say remembering tacos for like 38 cents
in the 90s they used to do shop as hard
tacos so tacos Miss miles just so fat
that's terrible oh you're right
yeah all right sorry that's not the
topics it's not one of these shows which
is like hey you know what I like uh
cream cheese sorry it's not gonna happen
I just as soon as I said talk about Mike
damn the fatness just hit me it's a good
reference I mean they stole their logo
Valentine it's all right guys here we go
today's episode is 100 not not
structured I had an idea while we were
doing the chat today and I thought Let's
uh
try this so I'm talking to you every
single one you put whatever you're doing
put it down listen there's so many
people out there hit us up every single
day how do you do this how do you do
that how did you start this what did you
do when this started how did you get to
where this happened how did you get your
business there today where it's going to
be called free game we're gonna give you
all the free game we could possibly
think of Marty's entire YouTube channel
is that that's what he's doing he's
trying to help little Marty that's like
19 or whoever old you are just trying to
help our younger versions of ourself
accelerate and uh expedite the process
man so real quick I'm going to start off
with people ask me every day like I will
get into the content but that's that's a
lot
um clothing how we talk about this the
first video I ever did on the adventures
of Viola channel is my second channel
the first video I ever did was how to
start a clothing company and
I'm just giving you guys my broken
knowledge kind of thing right so push
restart I had no idea what I'm doing
obviously and then we didn't know what
we were doing writing notebooks taking
orders on email and then we found ship
station plug crazy but yeah our our
sponsor this this episode and uh we
found ship station the first episode I
did was every single thing I could
possibly think of to help expedite I
have lost so much money sample fees
um paying for stuff I really didn't need
to pay for putting extra things on the
clothes that just cost money that you
throw away anyway nobody cares about it
it's not substantial enough so basically
what I wanted to do today is kind of
like give a little small breakdown on
the clothes because and it's any small
business I'm about to do this too I know
I know so any any small business Marty's
about to start putting out his epic
Marty's a photographer at heart so Marty
has some really sick pictures and
putting them on the inside of jackets
maybe the outside of jackets maybe on
this you have so many shots of app I
mean you can't just print people you've
taken pictures of but you have a lot of
I want to combine I want to combine the
photography with like hand-drawn
elements splashed on them with like some
graphical elements whatever just could
and then tie it in with like a meaning
like almost like a title yeah like an RP
these are art pieces but you oh you can
wear it yeah that's that way I'm
thinking of it okay so that's what
Marty's about to do so this is literally
how I would start that go to
legalzoom.com and get an LLC it's the
easiest thing you can do it's the
cheapest thing you do unless you're good
with that paperwork most people aren't
most people doing clothing and like
creatives aren't like you know what I
know what doc this is and what title I
need just go to just pay the six seven
hundred bucks what it is get started um
if you can buy bags and you can buy Zips
with your homies and go out and buy some
new Jays don't do it three times and go
get your business started that's all
it's going to take don't buy a zip this
month save it for a couple months maybe
you know struggle for a little bit and
then you're gonna get there so go get
your LLC this is the thing I wanted to
do
push trees the whole thing like you use
it's your art you want to do something
with it you're not more like oh how come
I charge how much can I make off of each
piece I haven't heard you say that yet
and that's good so the number one thing
I think for people is making stuff you
want to make just
because it's dope and it's fun that's
cool and then if the money comes epic
every successful person I've heard
starts like that I haven't literally
even considered money I know you have
this I know I know you have it
um so that's the that's the way to start
like with push trees you're like yo it'd
be cool my biggest fear was like I hope
people don't hate it because I love it
you know it's like a your favorite song
and you're like Thomas it's my favorite
song and Marty that's a wax song Marty
oh God then you even though you know
it's cool you're like
also hey I love that song but shut up
that's how it feels when you're like
you're putting out tangible things like
you've put out intangible things
vulnerable You're the most vulnerable
it's like uh
walking out to a bodybuilding
competition you haven't seen anybody you
go to him I've been working hard oh my
God I was gonna leave yeah so I care
about this marathon coming out yeah so
yeah Rosie ran the marathon yesterday
Adam shout out to Adam Mill he's been on
the show this full ran the marathon and
he was smoking a joint mile or something
he was hitting it and running stream the
whole thing I think that was epic then
he got on TMZ yeah TMZ
but Sammy Tony's wife and Rosie both ran
it
see Rosie wasn't even sweating after
like what do you mean like when I got
her like you have makeup on are you
serious it didn't look like a mangled
like hair perfect
cool like crawling across I was hurt my
foot hurts I was I had to walk on too
much two miles away and then oh gee I
just parked in the red he was right at
the Finish Line I could not believe it
was Thunder raining I'm like two miles I
just put my hood up in case somebody's
like yo what a rally I don't I don't
know you but uh sorry anyway continue
damn rant City happens quick
you just want to make things you like
right so I suggest if it's out if you're
out there go get a job and then do what
you want to do because
what you want to do is probably not
gonna make your money rather bat you
know but you have a job you have all
these things that's why you're like I
think I would like to do this so my
advice to everyone out there make stuff
that you think is awesome because like I
said earlier you hate that like you love
that song like that is whack you're
gonna find so many more people that like
this song too that artist doesn't just
have one fan oh this is this girl and
you know I was a struggling rapper but
that's different so the way I'm seeing
is like make stuff you like the first
couple things I made I'm like whoever
wears this I'd probably be friends with
because that's pretty funny not this but
it was like there's a shirt but the
first shirt did you even have a vision
for it as like a clothing line when you
put out like a shirt no so um everybody
knows the story but I'll just do a brief
one
um I did the picture I thought it was
funny and posted it
it's I'm for everyone out there that
makes stuff or maybe even you for music
like something you're like oh my God
this is it this is the one this is so
dope you put it out and goes that's it
nobody really cared and you put out some
like ah filler and it blows up yeah are
you kidding me yeah of course so with
push trees
I was like you know what
let's make the shirt the sweater it was
two two shirts three shirts two sweaters
and we sold out so fast it's just a logo
just the logo and then the tree one
and then one shirt that just said
dopasiola in cursive my logo okay I sold
out first surprisingly
um I've never made my name on a shirt
again I just I feel odd I don't know why
I feel like
it makes me feel like yo chill chill a
little bit
um I know people ask every day bro every
day except me and you put ourselves on a
shirt but that was epic mixtape yeah
that was dope I wouldn't care if that
wasn't me or yeah
we didn't design that one
um so we sold out and then Kush friendly
from Pittsburgh they said hey you times
for the traffic that I've ever had even
on Black Friday just for this drop you
could probably make a brand I go for
real he goes bro you probably sell more
than I would in like five years right
now like are you serious I remember I
was standing with my tech N9 poster to
the right I'm actually posted to the
left straight is my TV to the left the
door to the right to my table and I went
brand on my hands
all right all right Clyde text him back
thank you so much so you just connected
with him through Instagram and had him
he's the first person to send me clothes
ever he's like hey you know be cool I'll
send you a box you sent me like 60
shirts
I couldn't believe I'm like dude someone
sent me something tangible yeah oh my
God I mean like 50 pictures for the guy
to say thank you I just thought it was
cool and then he's like yo I'll help you
with the production he paid for
everything up front everything
it was just a collaboration now that I'm
uh I own push trees and if I saw him
like yeah let's do I'll pay for it don't
trip I get now while he did it like
you're gonna break so much traffic to my
site I get now oh we're being sold off
his site off his side I don't even have
push trees
a logo and uh that's how it started so
it was never to make money at first I'm
like I just hope it does well and when
it did well I'd even think about them I
just thought of
all right people like this yeah and then
I went oh my God there's more money I've
ever made legally in my life and then
that's how I just started funneling the
content by paying for for through the
push trees so when it comes to this do
me a favor go watch it's called how to
start a clothing company on the
adventures of Yola Channel
I break down everything that I knew at
that time that was 2019. yeah now I
don't know how I was seven years in I
knew nothing
three years later it's like are you
kidding me how did I gain so much
knowledge how was I so dumb earlier
scary though for that long not even
almost signed away my life to somebody
once you know like I can't believe and
then I get older and think you're such a
piece for try to play me like you're 10
years older than me you're a bad person
how do you think I feel now oh I know
but now what all those dudes are almost
50 going I lost it oh he's crushed it
now I shouldn't have tried to play that
kid that's a lot of people in your life
in my life but
continue push trees I've never done an
influencer package I've never sent stuff
to people exceptions that's true
like I've said a thousand free Church to
fans that are dope and they're cool as
hell or or like they ordered before but
it's here put a note no trip and they're
always so stupid I wonder like a
celebrity though no I've never said
anything to a celebrity
um I sent this guy I know does the uh
well you know what's the
Film Festival that everybody goes to in
Utah I think it is it's like the film
festival Sundance
I don't know where that's so this guy I
know is the coordinator for Sundance
right and he loves my content he goes I
know you're a small company but if you
want I have every celebrity on the
planet I got their gift boxes and I'll
put you in for free it's 25 bands to be
on the list to be able to put your stuff
on the table for the celebrities right
it's expensive you know it was 25 bands
he goes I got you I go and that's where
my rent was 600 bucks still and I was
like struggling I'm like do you want but
I gotta give you clothes and I thought
oh
all right and I gave him like 25 pieces
of thing and I thought that was the most
detrimental loss of my life I've never
lost that much legal like that was my
rent money going I'm like all right you
know what it's gonna help that's the
only thing I ever did but Public Enemy
all wore it
oh everybody no was it Naughty by Nature
I want to say Naughty by Nature they all
were at the BET Awards my shirt and
that's how I got sued by Tupac's family
connecting dots right now okay I did a
design oh another thing if you're gonna
do stuff that's gonna be seasoned assist
ish sell it fast as you possibly can
okay if you're gonna put artists on your
clothes hurry up with it it was one of
the best designs you ever did I love the
design I put push trees instead of Thug
Life on him on his tattoo on his stomach
and he had a pistol it looked so real I
had someone draw in half tone dots I
drew it in dots and I put it on the
shirt and they loved the shirt so much
they were all worn on the BT Awards
while they were performing and then
Tupac's estate lawyer was there
screenshot from that I never got
anything but the guy texted me and
letting me know they wore it never saw
nothing I gave away 25 pieces and was
like I got nothing but sued
how long after three months did they
actually sue you
I think the guy thought I was just some
dummy he's like I want every address to
everybody I was like you can eat a dick
bro and I just never hit the lawyer back
I'm like you can eat a dick with that
and I just said he never hit me back up
because he's like you think you're gonna
like strong Army to give up information
is the craziest thing I ever heard
people's personal information to him
yes every single shirt I ever sent to
anybody in their address yeah I gotcha
um
so that was an investment that I just
got sued or like scared yeah you're
gonna be like he started this he started
everything and I'm like ah I don't sell
them anymore who cares and I think he
found out we're a small company probably
made a thousand dollars off it and was
like uh well how many and how many like
followers on IGS you have when you first
started 25 000. okay yeah so it wasn't
that big and then how long until you
guys were like okay we're confidently
paying our bills off this
seven years later every month was like I
hope I can pay my bills off this I told
you I just stopped trying to sell sell
weed
what's up guys spring is sprung and our
friends over at manscape have brought
you the perfect tools for spring
cleaning and your pants trust me guys
when you're clean your confidence is up
everything else is better we all know
manscape's the leaders and below the
waste crew and and they're back to
change the way we take care of our
hygiene with the performance package 4.0
so guys inside this ball care bundle
you're going to find the lawnmower 4.0
trimmer weed whacker ear hair trimmer
nose hair trimmer crop preserver ball
deodorant the ball toner toner
performance boxer briefs and it all
comes with the travel pack you know me
and Marty use it for everything the
lawnmower 4.0 is the elite electric
trimmer that provides the proprietary
skin safe technology this trimmer is
designed to trim on loose skin and
although your balls might look like
punching bags we want to be nice and
gentle with them for those of you out
there doing this in the dark this is for
you you know the lawnmower 4.0 is
waterproof you already know that and for
everyone out there trimming in the dark
there's a light on it all right for all
you on the go nocturnal dudes out there
they're back with the proprietary skin
safe technology on the weed whacker ear
a nose hair trimmer the proprietary skin
safe technology reducing snags Nicks and
tugs on all your delicate holes and skin
and it's almost summer time don't get
sweaty ball syndrome go get the crop
reserver ball deodorant for manscaped go
to manscape.com Yola for 20 off and free
shipping plus you're getting two free
gifts the performance boxer briefs and
the shed travel bag I got two shed
travel bags in use at all time
landscape.com Yola 20 off and free
shipping use code Yola check out so look
your best this spring guys your balls
will thank you remember that's code
yolet check out 20 off plus free
shipping
[Music]
foreign
guys if you know me you know I'm buying
things online constantly all the time as
a consumer there's been plenty of times
where I'm going to check out and I get
through the checkout process I'm still
in the cart I get to the shipping and I
just I really don't want it that much to
pay that much for shipping and I back
out and abandon the cart happens all the
time if you own your own e-commerce
store you know about it from the other
side have you ever left your car because
shipping was too expensive probably so
the ship station you avoid all that from
the business owner's perspective lower
cost save on shipping keep your
customers happy guys running a business
can be stressful I know from experience
but for the past five years I've been
using ship station for post trees and
it's taking stress off my life daily if
you've been on the fence with ship
stations Now's the Time to try it out
it's a quick setup and it's free trip
station makes it easy to handle all your
orders online from one single dashboard
shipstation effortlessly integrates on
any site you might have from Etsy to
Amazon to Shopify ship stations provide
one simple clean easy to use dashboard
for all your orders as Marty said it's
all under One dashboard everything under
the sun is right there makes it so easy
it is the expedited way for you to learn
how to do shipping I'm telling you took
me four years till I finally found
shipstation and it's made everything
easier with the best discounts in the
industry you'll never have to worry
about overpaying for shipping get up to
84 off USPS and UPS rates and if that's
not enough use our promo code dope as
usual for two months free of ship
station over 130 000 businesses have
used ship stations and 98 of people
never leave remember that's code dope as
usual and that's two free months 60 days
for everyone out there with a small
business now is the time to take
advantage shipstation.com use our code
dope as usual
[Music]
Jack
yes
[Laughter]
um wow this is um can anybody help us be
real smokers can you even have a lighter
I do yo never mind thank you thank you I
am so prepared I'm so prepared but not
that is it in your back yeah yeah so
were you doing like I know I'm
podcasting the most success that I've
seen that happen in podcasting with
merch is like The Limited drop you know
it's like oh it's putting all your [__]
in my pockets you know what's crazy
about those Oakleys
what they're like polarized or something
I don't even know if that's the word but
missing stop sign it's like you're
tripping out the way light like you
start seeing like rainbows from the sky
the glasses it is it's like okay do I
want to kind of trip out a little bit
put these on oh this is so fun I wish I
had a life where I can be like yeah I
want a trip now but what's interesting
about it is like if April puts it on she
sees
she'll see all the the full rainbow in
the sky but then I'll put it on a nazia
but then cam will put it on and he'll
see it and it's like you kind of see
things differently depending on it's all
these different lightwaves coming
through Peter Pan you grew up
I think your brain grew up and you're
not allowed to see it man damn it you
better start act like a kid in school
and your kids I was just telling April
like you know I'm never going to be an
adult right it seems like you're an
adult that's good but just so you know
um
Marty what happened what were we talking
about sorry clothing guys this episode
is all over the place like these walls
that's this episode and my attention
span if you really look around this is
that oh you have an idiot Jack so shout
out to cbx I just want to say cbx one of
my favorite Brands I've been linking
with them lately
didn't put me on all these old school
strains dude that I haven't seen in so
long they're one of the few brands that
I'm like you guys really care about
every step of the process down to the
full breaking it up like you guys care
was there a facility all like at Coast
or was it like simpler simpler
and they're one of the largest companies
in California right now and they're one
shop like one facility all in-house I
told you uh one of the owners used to uh
do clothing and the pandemic shut them
down so instead of firing all the old
Mexican ladies he hired him at a trim I
trained him in a trim and I walked in
with a bunch of old grandmas and aunts
it's like a Netflix show yeah it was
very cool
um sorry back on what I was saying
making stuff that you like is the key
like you said when people make music
like I make music for myself you hear
that about artists all the time
and then it catches on it's never and
the people that are always waiting and
hoping and
you know that rapper you know that
rapper it's probably you so chill
when they walk in the room oh yeah I
make music Hey listen to my [__] like yo
chill out I didn't even ask you what you
do I don't even know your name yet I was
in this
I won't get into it but someone pulled
that to me the other day on me the other
day and after I left John was like
you're so nice I would have told him to
get away from me 30 seconds I don't know
it was a fine line you gotta know this
guy was bugging the [__] out of me and
I'm like you're so nice that I can't
break your heart but please get away
from me I just want to like get away
from was it in public what was that
Burberry during a meeting during a damn
showing and I went in and I said yo
what's up I need management and I go
um I think that I think he works there
he goes no no I'm an artist I need music
management
that's the worst way uh
oh I like that chain how much that cost
that's what he said to Tom like all
right adjacently uh
yeah man they're sleeping on me man
they're sleeping on me he said it's 62
times in a row I'll go
okay oh yeah I make music
bro I'm just trying to shop for
something I'm out of me like I'm doing a
viewing and it turned out to me
exchanging emails 20 minutes later
because after all that I just need a
break I just need people to see me I
just got this
I just need money I'm like okay you need
money why are you in Burberry first off
bad decision being in here sir why are
you in here shopping any money and then
he said
what do you do like oh we just do we
stuff he goes oh I need a job man I'll
work for oh what do you do I was like I
think you want to be a rapper he's like
yeah but you know I need a new job
okay so what do you do I want to do
wheat [__] oh what's your name I was
like dude everything in me just a
Charlie Murphy everything in me says
stop this [__] out right here man
they're getting Chevelle's showing up
for real he was nice but I'm like I wish
they could just smush you away from me
there's a really little dude and he kind
of had a limp so I'm like I can't be
mean to this dude yeah of course disc by
fools because he has a horrible
personality I thought he knew who you
were going into the story that's why I
just asked three random strangers on the
management I'm like oh he works here no
no I'm an artist
on a record label for this Burberry yeah
thank you that's why I'm like you're in
here in Los Angeles
anyway long story short game of email
he's like I'll work in a factory how
much do I get paid I'm like oh my God
take this email hit us up if you want he
never hit us up but you've had thousands
of people pitch themselves to you like
oh yes yes the ones that you remember
well how did they do it as one guy hit
me up is that I've been watching you for
a long time I do podcasting and I think
I can help you out that was you
that's it bro what about in line at the
meet and greets people got to be rapping
at you and going oh yeah that I thought
you meant like
in yeah yeah yeah oh I don't know
there's and if they if they worked then
I gave them emails switched emails and
let it go from there you're quick to
like and those meet and greets like
you're just so quick to be like no let
me genuinely actually help you and take
your yes and the meet and greets is
different those people came there for a
purpose yeah I'm like yo what are you
doing take this email down
I got you you know I mean like I got you
but this dude anyway I don't know how we
got on that subject but oh rapper [__]
you can't be that guy and with clothing
like the rapper thing if those people
that are so striving to like not about
the Arts not about what you're doing
it's about you I need to be popping I
need to make money same thing goes to
clothing same thing goes with small
businesses like yo you got to do that
like because you want to do it unless
it's like I am not a chef and I have a
restaurant like okay you're just in a
business different yeah but when it
comes to clothing it comes to everything
comes to all this I think it you you
have to genuinely be genuine
that's the only way this works because
I ain't gonna wear your shirt you got a
bad Vibe even though you're sure it's
tight like I will not do it a lot of
this stuff is people don't understand
social media is so huge and prevalent
when it comes to having a brand a small
business everything every time someone
has a business go what is your Instagram
what is your website what is your this
how can I contact reach and see without
being in PR you know how do I contact
without being present and I think people
um need to realize that social media
plays such a big game and I'm not saying
if your Instagram sucks you're not
selling I'm saying just making it aware
that you exist all right because the
world is on social media every single
time of course I mean oh a actor or
anybody comes to ESPN
Twitter name pops up every time right
any time you'll see Twitter name pops up
yeah because it's social media and it's
a way to promote the people within your
organization so when it comes to
clothing like I said I never said
anything to anybody I think just because
one I couldn't afford to and two I don't
want anybody going you know I've been I
helped you get popping like no you
didn't the fans did the fans did are you
a fan
I don't remember you
you know that's why it's like no I'm not
going to say nothing to you that's how I
felt about it but now I'm starting to
see like dude stop being that way just
it's it's like getting your name out
there yeah I get it totally I get it so
that's where you build it on other
people's fans I didn't try to build it
on other well it's not it's not a bad
thing like if there's clothing companies
out there starting with collapse who
cares it's great but that's how I that's
how I did it kind of like a because the
fans are gonna I'm in a unique situation
where the owner I'll show the guy you
watch on videos so you get to see the
transparency between yeah if I was a
liar you would have caught it already
yeah like somebody would have been like
no you said in this story that you did
that like what's so great about push
trees though is that it's like a subtle
like uh it's not dope is Yola it's its
own nod to a whole community so it's
like you're that's what I would want
that's what like I would try to
encourage anybody to do is like yes this
is in the lane of what I'm passionate
about and what I do but it's not me I'm
stepping outside of myself for something
that everybody can kind of identify with
and want to put on themselves I don't
smoke blunts my biggest selling is the
homies for Life the other one was that
can you hear me now I don't smoke blunts
but I know like the audience like for
music I'm sure some rappers have dropped
a line of a brand just because they know
like oh they don't let people like that
one at rhyme too went well I don't even
own that shirt yeah same thing but was
it I wear hard rack Hard Rock uh Fiji
I've never been to Fiji like I'm always
sunny it's the same thing it's just
people want to rep something people
wanna
there's not much you could do to your
own body to make yourself different and
or not like the same guy over and over
and over like like a you know it was
just like a mold of the same dude that's
next to the next like Slim Shady yeah
exactly great reference goes like that
like how do you be yourself
like clothing that's an expression all
right people tattoo themselves why
to express certain things so when it
comes to clothes when you see a shirt
you see a hat you see a direction we're
doing it all came from someone's brain
so when it comes to these clothes and
people love it it makes me
if I did I go how many times I said I
don't care anyway never made no money
like as long as this [__] it's dope when
I'm dead and old I'm stoked but it
always thank God it did but with clothes
same thing like you're wearing my shirt
in your chest that is it blows I've only
seen three people like in person rocking
outside of weed stuff like rocking our
[__] fully I blew up and lost my mind
every single time one lady who thought I
was an idiot she had no idea who was
treated it was her son's shirt just
happened to wear it I was just going now
it's like thank you so much like I don't
know what this is like oh man I didn't
you rude [__] but you know what I mean
like
that's I'm still two so I've been doing
this ten years like if I see you're
gonna Sheridan I'm gonna get something
excited just because that's what
happened if I see it with some pressure
you know what I'm saying like it's so we
connect it's it's like a uh what was it
the 50s all the Stoners here we go in
the 50s all the starters I didn't know
about that my grandma Dolores had one
she put a little dot right there it's
called a stoner dot it's so when you
were like we're chilling you could just
be okay
yeah that's what she got it okay Daddy
wow Dottie and uh she likes Dottie from
uh Pee-wee Herman okay that was
International like yo what's up dude
yeah I smoke too uh-huh plus three
shirts International
I smoke too I don't know do we try to do
this little like
if you know what push trees is you're
down if you don't exactly maybe you will
but even if you don't it's still like
some funny logo yeah it's such a great
iconic logo that's what and what makes a
great logo to me it's you can see it's
small as a little word Mark you can
recognize it huge it can go black it can
go white but it's just that Stark bold
because like
as a designer it's really hard not to be
influenced by like what you see other
people doing basically but I think so in
the elements of like brand design it's
so unique and just so like
bald in a way too because it's like
talking about selling weed but it's
funny it conjures up questions yeah
exactly so many what is this and that's
the best that you could ever do you
could have somebody walking down a dad
yeah I've had plenty of doubts of course
soccer what is that huh all right
culture stuff like yeah we we're
excavators I've told people put trees
excavation until oh
because I don't want to break the old
lady's heart like it's so weird oh yeah
so yeah I'm like oh excavators I just
keep walking
um I tell everybody I do podcast
protection every I don't do any I tell
them nothing it just doesn't even
wondering anything everyone that walks
in my house what do you do production
every single time because they're like
you live here every time now that people
come to my house like we're like
work or any like maintenance anything
like wow yeah uh production that's why I
say every time and I lie about it I
think you're in the marketplace I always
lie about who what comedian's been doing
oh yeah so and so they go really yeah
I've never even met that guy I just
don't want you to know what I do I just
don't uh like people knowing but anyway
um because that where I'm at it's my
house I'll just know where I live oh
that guy's house yeah exactly yeah
where's he live we should Rob that fool
Once you walk through that door but I
have to go to court and all that stuff I
just rather not and that's my biggest
fear anyway back to not ranting clothes
uh-huh guys I'm not a designer I don't
know clothing I don't know Tech packs I
don't know anything I have been
until two weeks ago or until I met Marty
ish
I I screenshot
Google blank black shirt screenshot it I
cut it out on my juice to poser app I
get my logo I put it over you've seen
you've seen it yeah that's how I do
everything and unless every drop we've
ever done Marty's making my mock-ups
nine minutes before it goes out because
I'm so preoccupied and busy and go oh my
God that's today I put drops off three
weeks in a row like I missed a Friday
again I do it all the time because I'm
so it's just everything's going on it's
yeah anyway so don't feel bad if you're
a business person and you're unorganized
I got organized last week so don't worry
that particular business though that
with that business only yeah with that
business because clothes kind of run
themselves I don't need to put out a new
shirt next Thursday like a video but you
also are in a position where you've kind
of been [__] sidelined and not really
had the time to like devote to it to get
it up and running to its full steam but
when uh when you were in your Heyday
were drops to push trees like how many
were you dropping at a time like are you
like there's a thousand oh so clothing
when I first started my orders were 144
to 228 a day 124 144 shirts that I would
buy every color or design oh okay yeah
288 are you talking about how many sales
we're doing
yeah like oh dude I have no idea we what
I thought was a lot of sales money-wise
um the most we ever our first two years
we made like 60k
like the first year I was like wow oh my
God gross income and you're sending
people from Instagram to homeboys
website basically no as soon as we did
that job pushtrees.com we made it he's
like you need to make a website make an
Instagram page I'm like all right I'll
do it and then I did I'm like oh I like
doing this this is fun first photo shoot
I ever took on 27th Street right by the
push trees house right by wild Tweakers
chill
my cousin and Rosie took a [__]
picture of them first [__] ad we ever
had and uh
I think it's like
yeah the first one was like 60 bands it
was like our best year the first two
years because it was so hard what it was
was uh I just did this because I just
hired somebody so I gave him the whole
story of bush trees but I couldn't
afford to make more new clothes if I had
5K I spent 5K in clothes they got done
in two weeks my rent's done is due in
two weeks so if I make that 2500 off
that 5K
I'm down to half okay cool but you
profited so I probably got like four
bands left the shirts but what happens
if I don't sell in a month 2500 goes to
the next rent now I'm down to fifteen
hundred dollars what about cars and
clothes I mean cars and food
how do I re-up on shirts
yeah you got to be an accountant to
figure all this out if you smoke a zip a
day basically and you're selling a zip a
day you don't make any money yeah yeah
like you're not making anything so
that's what I was doing I was spending
all the profit to pay for my rent so I
could just think of new stuff to make or
try to get it done so that's that was my
problem for a long time and then 2019 it
kind of changed how did you get past
that I just started actually making
money doing content any money I ever
made the first money I ever made I just
put it back into content and close yeah
and that's all I ever did all the way up
through season two yeah all I ever did
dude
um
so yeah I did nine years of not taking a
paycheck not taking
anything not having a shed yeah but
struggling hoping to get rent every
month but that's closed like that's
if I had the investment I could have
took those Investments so but I didn't
want to do that because I wanted to do
it on my own stubborn but I would have
who knows where we'd be but because you
did it like that you're able to then
flip push trees into the podcast
yeah Matt paid for that because I was
like okay this could help pay for this
whole Warehouse I'm like yeah just was
the whole driving force behind even
being able to get it started that's the
most yeah powerful thing because it's
like you didn't you could have just been
the push trees dude forever if you
really wanted to yeah I think about it
all the time like if I just stuck to one
thing could you imagine if I just made
content I didn't do clothes do the ream
I do the dough I did another like I
would pump out a video every other day
but where am I going to be financially
yeah pay for it on I don't get paid
smoking a zip a day again it's almost a
day again basically exactly like I'm
just I could just stay here forever but
this is what I want to get into now so
basically my advice for anybody with a
small business of clothing go to LLC go
get yours LegalZoom it's the easiest
thing you're gonna do extra 500 bucks
will give you a lawyer for two months
help you through the whole process don't
mess it up go get your make sure you're
getting a bank card go to the account
get it opened up under your business
account you might have to do a DBA doing
business as it takes like 30 days you
have to put your at your name in the
newspaper it's like saying that you're
legitimate and then that's it that's how
I that's why I swipe as dope as Yola
yeah like I have a car that just says
that yeah they don't teach you this is
the most important thing ever they don't
teach you in high school is like when
you set off like okay I'm gonna be my
own business owner this is the first
thing that you have to do because this
legitimizes you to the government yes so
that you can set up your business
checking account because if you don't do
all this you're gonna end up getting
audited or having issue issues with the
tax man so when you really set up and
you're serious and what I like like when
I got with my money manager she's like
yeah no you're a real business you got
to do all this stuff you got to set it
up this way and it just makes you think
in a certain it makes you think like a
business owner rather than just a dude
everything you do this is my next piece
of advice
I wore this jacket on this episode today
it's five of them I can now write off
some of this jacket
I do film I do social media I'm the face
of our company
there's a reason why I buy stuff I'm
like you know what
I get a discount basically because I've
come tax time
it's gonna help not just saying like I
go buy stuff and write it I'm not saying
that I gotta do videos I'm on camera
with it I do photo shoots with this like
there's a reason why I can do it if
you're out there right now and you're
just doing clothing and you're not on
camera and you just have a business
write off your gas take care of your
miles every mile that you drive when
it's according to your business you can
spend up to 11 or 33 dollars a day I
can't remember what it is now on food if
you're working that day
eat lunch write it up yeah you're taking
money out of your own checking account
but come tax time like no I spend 11
that day
eat that off my taxes every single thing
your hair now people that are on camera
say you're a model say you're on YouTube
or you do a podcast every haircut you
keep track of that every time you go get
a facial every time you buy facial cream
every time you get a juice and you're
working like keep track of every single
thing you do miles on your car gas fill
up every time you go to work or you're
going to your office or you're making
content or your cameraman you buy them
lunch take track of that that's your
employee keep a track of everything when
you give them a W-9 at the end of the
year
you got to keep track of everything
because
if not how about this don't keep track
of it just let the government keep it
just do that if you want keep the change
every everywhere you go just say keep
the change then if you don't care that's
pretty much what you're doing if you're
not keeping it in line your house if you
work from home I work from home to 2020.
if you were from home I think it's 62
percent of my rent I read off my whole
house was full of post trees gear I just
had a bed and a couch
you know what I mean my internet my
phone bill is all under pushed trees why
because I use that phone to make calls
not all of it
but that's what this is about make sure
you take it there's a reason why like
those Rich dudes stay Rich because they
know every little thing they know all of
these things everything you do you watch
like TV on break maybe you should add
some your electricity on there maybe you
should talk to your accountant maybe you
should get an accountant or go to H R
Block and pay an extra fee and go hey
how can I really break this down this is
what I do every single day this is my
business I made clothes how much you
make three thousand how much your rent
two thousand so you're barely making
money yeah
so basically the boat would be like oh
and then rent or a car payment this you
made 100 this month like yeah but you
ate 300 worth of food you're in debt 200
I was like [__]
okay so the closer is fronting me every
week and every month just fronting me
like enough for the worst the worst so
basically
keep track of everything
everything like Marty bought that you're
wearing on the show it matches the set
looks really good make sure you keep
track of that when you talk to your
accountant they'll ask you and tell you
how much it was 60 bucks you can write
off 39 of it because whatever the
legality thing is I know a lot of things
I'm saying people know but if you don't
know it's mind-blowing I'm still
mind-blowing yeah I'm still working on
all this haircut I pay with zeld so at
the end of the year I know exactly which
Barber and I go I paid him that much
this year yeah because when you work for
yourself you have to back all all these
amounts you've done back off of the
total that you made because all you're
just getting money just to yourself
and then you pay tax on that that's how
it works so like the the easiest
explanation because I know taxes are
confusing you made fifty thousand
dollars this year as a
photographer but you never pay taxes you
know you don't say you work at
McDonald's you made 300 bucks she made
like 200 because the taxes right
so every time you get the money out of
your paycheck it goes to the government
but when you work for yourself as a
business owner your responsibility is to
hold on to that tax money so at the end
of the year you made 50 you owe us 21.
well I spent on the discipline to just
have that in a little savings oh yeah we
put it in our savings every single month
I mean Rose like oh this is the sales
tax this month because it's come to the
end of the year like thirty thousand
dollars now oh good thing I saved it
because the money never really was yours
you're collecting taxes yeah so really
you're pocketing extra money that you
think you have and it makes you think
you got more money than you have totally
and if you're not organized what happens
you owe the government money you get a
giant truck
or Bill I should do yeah so I I know it
kind of sounds simple to people that
done this but it's not simple to people
that have it because it's it's hard dude
this is hard it's hard to keep track so
it's crucial yeah so when it comes to
clothing boom that's how you do it
that's how I would do it and now I'm not
a designer I don't have the time to
really
put into push trees that I think I need
to and I always say I'm going to get it
done I put off days but what happens if
I have stuff to do that day and I have a
regular life I have to go to the doctor
or go to the store and do this stuff
comes up it's life but
the way I'm looking at it is uh I have
to delegate like you said you have to
delegate or it's not going to work
I will work 24 hours a day but I've been
doing that for 10 years I got burned out
like right when Rosie did her surgery I
was slept for like two days and went
just
caught I just felt like 10 years of not
sleeping just hit me all at once and I
just got lazy for like three months but
I realized like I need to delegate if I
can do if this is going to work push
trees can't prosper and dobizola and the
podcast and the dopest and the camp
which is me quick can't do the back end
with everything so I hired somebody I
told you right I heard so I hired
somebody guys a little quick update for
push trees I've been taking forever on
this show you one of this yeah
um a little update right
I've been if you follow me on Twitter
um or SnapChat you see I've been saying
it by two months I want to hire a
creative director for push trees I need
somebody that I can go hey your brain's
kind of like my brain
trust you run everything by me when
you're done [__] that you're like I'm
not like I'm still that's how it's
supposed to yeah right so when I went to
ethica I inspired the hell out of me I
told you that just going in like yo that
was a trickle-down effect you related to
him you related to him he gets it done
she does this wow the whole Project's
done the guy was having a meeting and
all of it got done while he was in the
meeting but he was there yeah people got
rolls yeah the roles were there it's
like an extension you're my arm yeah
you're this arm imagine you're trying to
run the dopest impossible
we have 15 20 employees wow never even
met half of them
like all the warehouse and yeah I
haven't been over so I guess I'm so big
there's no way I could go over there and
like be there on the daily it's
impossible so basically guys
I hire somebody and I've been telling
you so I hire somebody and you guys know
I told you on Twitter I want to hire
somebody with experience I do not want
to have I don't want to grow with
anybody I've grown as far as I'm gonna
grow by myself
not going anymore
if we're the biggest podcast on Earth
Tomorrow push trees is not gonna
podcast push trees is gonna grow like
this still it'll grow
but it's never going to be where it's at
just the way I'm doing it now who cares
if you got a huge podcast what if you
don't have any gear and you're not
having new designs yeah you don't have a
printer anymore like who cares and it's
like yo yeah the most fire we haven't
seen in three years yeah like who cares
nobody cares anymore so I hired somebody
so guys
shout out to Jay I hired him we're gonna
bring him on we're gonna see how it's
gonna really work over time
but I drove you a breakdown this dude
um
help start V loan help start Ben Trill
help do Revenge shoes
help curate a lot of the complex con
Nike uh V loan pop-ups so like his
brains is like he's exactly my age
Mexican dude smokes fire only like
almost like to a stop point which was
great yeah and uh we just smashed did he
come up with that lookbook you showed me
yes
never had a lookbook before yeah that
was great
so come up with it so did you give him
direction or you just gave him some
designs and say hey what would you do
with some of this stuff that's it
that's that's really The Telltale sign
of a really good artist who can just
take a little bit of like not even that
the last last meeting brought a designer
with them we sat for four hours just
talking doing stuff me giving examples
of stuff I loved as a kid and then I
went tags reinvent tags we want to do
something else with our Tech every event
redesign our tags so I went through all
the designer [__] I'm like I love
that part of this I love the little hit
of color here I love this and we're not
going to bite that we're going you see
all of this
it's a mood board yeah like a verbal
movement yeah like the vibe of like yeah
that's clean as hell but I could wear
that like to my homie's garage so just
about blunts you know that's kind of our
Vibe like yo that'd be like that what
about how to push trees logo in the
middle so sick oh my God
sweater but you see like I can look at
that look at the design and go I like
hockey sweaters it's not like we're like
bite that like no I like hockey sweaters
I didn't know I did yeah now maybe we
have something there but we can be
brought the designer we're like working
our brains are like going together we're
trying to do this we're trying to do
that and my homie Tyler I hired him too
to help me on the day today like Keurig
Collections and then I go to my new guy
Jay and like we all brainstorm we have
the 420 collection dropping on 420 I've
never had a 420 drop
we have one month till today it's gonna
get done we're gonna have assets
and content to drop the days before
coming up to it I've never had content
okay yeah ready to go yeah schedule yes
shout out to floor mats formats the the
dude nice
um I haven't told him yet by the time it
comes out I'm gonna have him curate the
whole push trees
roll out the new one like take pictures
of us and we're like that movement [__]
[Music]
the new collection coming out it's very
simple but it's so tight I'm excited
um I haven't told you about the patches
yet we're going full High designer with
streetwear still like the little things
you're like that's like on
like Burberry [__] like I I know it is
that's the other important thing that
you always got to consider especially
when you get into clothes is like how
many things can I add on to still keep
margins it's like you're playing this
battle with like your quality and your
margins up until this point where you're
at now basically
um
I don't know how do you have any advice
for people on how to like deal with that
because like this is I choose all the
comments I I I talk to everybody
I hate when I hear people complaining
[__] unless it's valid
of course like when it's bad I go oh
I'll work on it damn you're right I
didn't see it before like when people
like you're charging a hundred and
thirty dollars for a grinder and I went
yeah I know I know I just said it like
70 times I hate it I hate the fact that
I have to charge that they're so
expensive they're oh damn near a hundred
dollars to make
you're supposed to double up on profit
yeah unclose you sell you make a shirt
for 14. you probably sell about 28
dollars you make a bong for ten you sell
for 20. you're supposed to double up all
right everything normal that's the base
minimum making thirty dollars on these
expensive writers that make people think
I'm a like a greedy [__] how many
people I haven't had to like [__] on
like you know chill break it down go you
think I'm pocketing like 90. I would
sell these for 40 bucks so anyway I'm
working on a new grinder right now
because I just it hurts my heart to
charge people that much that's cool
through the rehab or through pressure
yeah I'll just do push trees
it really hurts dude it makes me feel
sad don't get the best grinder on Earth
then if it's not free it is the best
writer on Earth
British as that's why it's if we can get
the best credit cheaper love it yeah but
uh we're going to switch it up really
good thing I just feel bad because I
remember what it was like being poor as
hell looking on Dr J's like damn that
shirt's 32 dollars
there's no way I gotta work I gotta find
something to do and then I was like damn
I'm poor
and I just went over my day I think like
that stuff I was like who cares
but as a kid like how can I make a 32
dogs always think like if I sell this
much weed but then I gotta re-up on it
then I won't be able to smoke and if I
can't smoke then what am I going to do
about this and then it would just never
work out that's how I feel like now when
people like damn I wish I could afford
it but [__] that bugs me it's like damn
dude a charge but then I'm gonna go
bro it's expensive material like I'm not
taxing you ever I promise if you can see
my back end you'd be like oh
that's reasonable like yeah I know it is
[__] you got to kind of just trust
that please don't think I'm a piece of
[__] that's all I'm trying to say yeah
behind that comment is you are kind of
accusing me of being abusive [__]
oh bro people bug me anyway when it
comes to that I think it's know your
audience bro if you're making Thrasher
metal crazy rip t-shirts and your
audience is drinking Bud Light Coors
Light and can afford five sacks maybe
not make a 75 shirt
yeah of course if I'm gonna make some
thrash metal [__] I'm going to sell a 20
t-shirt if you're if you were dealing
with somebody who didn't have a ton of
overhead but had really good artwork
would you advise them to go in the
direction of like finding the production
getting the inventory or okay going with
like a printful style Company online I
gotta be honest I'm still until I met
James still like in the air with with
printing
10 years in I like all this guy messed
up but this person messed up then again
I'm the pickiest most
detail-oriented Fool on the Earth
I just don't like to feel played
like all that shirt's messed up
you're playing me why do I not get my
[__] in full that's how I feel like so
my money was oh it was was it did they
give you different currency oh I gave
you American money then you should give
me my [__] that's how I feel like don't
try to play me that's all like I'm super
stoked and nice if you ever see me in
public or if something being a dick it's
because someone tried to play with me
that's all I just don't feel like when I
was a kid everybody used to [__] with me
and it makes me feel like when I was a
kid like letting it go by yeah like as a
kid like oh I'll just I'll just not say
anything that's fine
I was a kid like I was like a little kid
you know I mean like oh bro but like I
don't mean like
if someone took my property I'd fight
him I'm talking about like oh I was
playing with that ball yeah that's all
right you can have it it's not even my
ball like I was never like the
confrontational yeah yeah of course but
like now it's more of like with these
printers that's why I go through them so
fast like this is your business
if my business was to make content for
you I'd perfect it and I wouldn't give
it to you unless it was right so if you
don't feel that way can't work together
we don't have the same work ethic and I
just don't [__] with you were you
fighting that battle the whole time
up until recently so um find a printer
and if not printful helps printful is a
printful.com they A to Z they can help
you out there's a bunch of look it up
direct to garment DTG direct to garment
that helps a lot that's just something
that will print your design with the
order comes in and they'll ship it for
you yeah you get some samples so you
know what you're selling and then just
how do ice break doesn't go down yeah so
it's like oh 20 shirt because you only
order 10. but what if I ordered 300 same
but with printing you say oh 300 all the
print goes way down cheaper but the
prince have there's variations uh it
could mess up if you cry unless you get
a good printer yeah DTG it's just boom
they like paste it with a laser on
basically that's interesting though I
didn't think about that but that's the
next thing especially in clothes that
you got to consider but the closer I
mean
it's not even one of those things where
you're like at some point I can really
own my whole like every facet of my
operation like
for a regular purse I mean that looks
like uh represent one of these huge
Brands that's like out here that started
from just a dude
you know you're gonna have to deal with
printers you're gonna have to deal with
artists unless you do all that yourself
but yeah
you yourself if you're going to be
probably want to be the face of it and
be worried about building a fan base in
the community around that but pretty
much um I just if you don't have the
work ethic like at home to like you know
that I I clean that
and if you know I clean it it better be
perfect or I look like an idiot or I
think I look like it if you don't have
that work ethic go work for somebody
else just real quick to ask yourself
like do I care do you pick up trash when
no one's around and if your answer is no
don't start your own business
simple as that if you're a restaurant
owner and your shit's dirty in the back
and you know it's dirty in the back and
you're continuing yourself that's 100
you don't love it you don't care
when your family comes over you make
sure your house is clean your house
should be clean all the time my house is
clean we clean the house before the
cleaners come which is insane bro I pick
up stuff I got cleaners for the first
time because Rosie had her surgery I'm
like dude I'm work I'm doing this I'll
just have like you know mop do this once
uh every 10 days will come because we
had high ceilings by Kevin come in like
do the windows and bounce like don't do
laundry don't do dishes don't do
anything else because I feel like a
weirdo already having you clean in my
house so I would be cleaning up while
they're cleaning up like alongside oh
yeah I'll help too I feel like a piece
of [__] just standing like you're
cleaning my house like
oh gross but when it comes to that if
you don't have that in your brain your
business is not going to thrive
as simple as that like who's gonna hold
accountable when you [__] up not you
yeah well the average person is going to
have to face about five to ten years of
brutal adversity to even touch success
so you got to know that going into it
off top too but also the way you said
that is exactly how I felt but it might
not be for you guys
the whole time I was struggling
it wasn't shitty but when it came to
business parts of money it was the worst
but it's not like I'm sitting there
depressed all day like thinking about
damn eight more years till this works no
to live your life make it part of your
lifestyle once it becomes part of your
lifestyle when it happens it happens
hopefully it does yeah you got to think
like I always thought as if already that
was always my mentality what's going to
happen my life is kind of coming towards
me now I'm me already though I think
that's really what it takes is to be in
line with that as how you think of
yourself going into it before it even
exists in this movie and You Know How It
Ends just you don't remember the middle
yeah exactly yeah yeah you're gonna get
there it's gonna happen it's gonna work
if you're not a piece of [__] we've said
it many times and if you work hard
that's really all I know people like you
work hard you could pull me I got
I got hit by a car and I worked Hardball
bro you got a bad bad card
it doesn't say just because you thought
you were that entitled that just because
your experience was like that that's the
basis of everything no so like I said
just because I was drugged doesn't mean
it's going to be the same that you're
going to go through just letting you
know how I felt and I hope yours is
easier
that's it so clothing
pretty much wrapped up that's where
we're at right now calling it right now
by the end of this year
bro
[Music]
we're gonna be so popping again like
what's what would be the goal like what
would the goal look like by the end of
the year best kiss scenario I want to
well I don't really want to talk about
any stuff online but
there's a number in my head if I can do
that every month I'll be happy
how many drops would it take to do it do
you think like monthly or like oh no
we're only good we're gonna be a real
clothing company it's four collections
three colleges a year that's it big
drops 15 pieces of everything oh Supreme
model bro okay I'll show you it after
but we're gonna go hard
we ready to Summers ready getting design
like I'm trying to map it out
wow accessories and like pool
accessories for summer and
stuff like you know when you go to a
store like damn that shit's hard I can't
believe that's gonna be us
I'm I'm I've never been excited about
post trees like this I'm like I am so
Juiced for this 420 drop
never had a 420 drop never had a 420
driver come on what are we doing here
that's insane but have you ever had the
artwork done I've never had the Motion
Graphics I never
and then after I reached out we've gone
on a deed I've had 30 designers and
never how many nine out of 10 designers
will just never hit me back up with the
stuff that we started on that's how it
always goes oh yeah I'll get back to you
sorry man I got you know I got caught up
like bro it's been a month and a half
oh my God so it's not for the lack of
trying I've tried well I'll try to
balance all these other things so
that's really what happened I got
neglected push trees because I was so
busy and I feel like
being honest if I didn't if I don't
touch push trees this year it could just
do this next year just be forgotten
about not as Pop I mean it could happen
to anybody and I could see it happening
because I got bored with it just looking
at the same post like dude get some new
clothes you got to keep it evolving yes
you have to be revolved I've been
Plateau for a year and a half I asked uh
chat GPT
what what's the point of life
and it pulled up this really cool
article it's uh the point of life is to
keep evolving I was like damn that's
right Christian Troy do you guys used to
watch Nip Tuck
yeah
I used to watch it I shouldn't watched
it was in high school what the hell was
I doing I was watching Nip Tuck he's
like
what was he say is like uh you might as
well be dead if you know if you if
you're perfect then you might as well
not might as well be dead like you can
always get better he said something
stupid FX but I just remember Christy
Troy said something I was like 15 like
yeah yeah he's balling and what a
terrible show for a kid to watch oh my
God bro
um anyway yeah dude keep evolving like
what can you do next what what could I
do next like how could you make this
better yeah and then once you're done
with that like how can I help out fools
I know I love taking like like hey what
would you do I bet you I can help you
out as long as it's a challenge
everything's like a challenge and now I
stop challenging my own brand it just
kept like coasting so now it's like yo
um I bet you I can do this with push
trees like I bet you I could do this
[__] yeah yeah because if you have the
confidence yeah now it's to yourself
it's like I bet you I could do it
I don't that's how I feel about YouTube
right now oh dude you're you're come on
right now Marty is giving you all the
game on photography videography editing
how to do this how to do that on his
YouTube It's Marty made it on YouTube
just starting out now that Marty has
more time because the podcast is not
being edited by us so now he has a
couple extra days
go check it out because I feel like
your your side is the side I miss I'm
missing like I don't know that Tech side
and I'm not saying you're only Tech guy
but you know that yeah and it was like
all the like the marketing wheat [__] is
like like yeah like I know that
put them together you know two different
channels but put them together we're on
our own show
might bring different people coming in
to watch a lot of value for yeah that
and it's more of a
who do you know on YouTube
that gives you fun stuff advice Peter
McKinnon's dope yeah I don't see Peter
McKinnon joining hundred thousand dollar
smokeouts I mean 100 grams Smokehouse
and it's not like oh we smoke weeded
better I'm just saying it's different
know this yeah yeah yeah you know what I
mean you know him oh you can teach me
how to do that like yeah go check my
channel out but that's what I do bro
come on man that's like Wayne's World
like by the way Wayne is of expert
nutritionist is that a channel
yeah it's funny it's like dude what's
another layer it's another layer man
because now that I think about it like
the dudes I learned from I didn't really
know that I'm going into it yeah but now
it's like oh I can learn I have so much
I just want to do it in a logical way
and get it out and be a part of it to
really like when I graduated college
they were like you should teach I mean
full sale yeah okay I was like you went
to college yeah
you know they do like an exit interview
and you you like graduate and stuff and
they were like that's what they said and
I was like I'd always love to do that
and there's so many different things I
could touch on top through YouTube we're
going to figure it out I'm gonna start
you know now that I have this extra time
started on that right away but I wanted
to be real deliberate about it and not
just
use my platform here to like just start
a channel I want to be real deliberate
in the type of videos I'm making my
approach to it and then like my own
personal brand yeah that's why I stopped
with the DraStic Graphics like
I grew that as a small business up to
the utmost point I feel like it could go
really like I've conquered like you're
doing graphics and then yeah so how you
up from there I still always have that
but now it's just you know it's just me
out here without a whole like small
business behind it my own personal brand
yeah that's you know and with uh with
with teaching like YouTube YouTube's the
biggest thing is how to's right how do
you really learn so the way I see it is
like uh
ready you teach a kid uh
how to shoot a basketball and the full
Miss is the first time you're like full
come on you know set up your elbow or
you do something right but what if he
misses you like don't even trip bro I
missed all my first shots let's get it
again that kid is gonna stick with you
yeah because you didn't just berate them
so same with learning like fools like
that's why I like I'm like the weed
teacher of like you are you can do this
don't trip don't trip because I used to
do that oh you guys are slippery because
I'm trying to give you examples like
that's how I feel that's how I feel
because if you can relate to somebody
even if you don't ready I don't speak
the same language and I bust out my
favorite movie that happens to be your
favorite movie we're friends but it
doesn't matter it's like oh I can relate
to you if you can relate to somebody I
feel like you can be susceptible to like
oh I can learn from you versus like this
is full though what do you know that I
don't know we better than me I can roll
joints like well then don't watch yeah
it's cool it's you it's yeah it's all
good yeah that's that's the way I see it
for you it's never thought about that if
you want to learn Photoshop I can show
you fast
you know it's comment leave comments
that's the best way for you to do more
stuff like how do you do this I got you
and it's uh like I said how to start a
clothing company how to get client like
you're you're giving people the
the patreon pass people charge for this
stuff
today yeah I want to make it I want to
make it make sense and I want to you
know there's so much to talk about
the channel enough to make it free
because YouTube's free if not Marty's
gonna have to go to patreon for doing 70
videos a week something like that some
course where I could actually talk to
the people in it and be a part of it and
we're gonna figure it out but I got I
got a lot of really useful information
where it's like unlock your creativity
and get money through it you know
because there's a lot that you're gonna
like we're talking about today the whole
episode this is what you're gonna come
up against going out after this
basically so as people that kind of went
up against it there's a there's a lot of
stuff that can save you time and money
out there boy that's the whole point of
trying to save you time and money
because I gotta be honest money's not as
important as time at all I wish if you
could bro what I wouldn't give to speed
you know what I knew 10 years ago oh my
God not have to just sacrifice your
twenties I did sacrifice my 20s but at
the same time I had the coolest 20s like
because I always thought of it as like
if I don't make money I don't make money
bro it's gonna be fun that's the only
way it was like I was able to do it for
free yeah that's how that was right it's
like one of those one day it was going
to be a new job I'll be stoked I was
doing it that's just the I think that's
the biggest thing and it goes back to
earlier but like you just gotta like
doing it so this gets it on to my next
part real quick
definitely not real quick content
that's the biggest how many kids do you
know that from camps I want to be a
YouTuber that is the number one fireman
cop doctor it does not matter anymore I
want to be a YouTuber I want to make
content is the biggest thing ever
because they see
75 of the content creators guys are up
front I'm just gonna let you know that
just
just put that there
not all these pools are just
balling and happy okay people are
struggling and they just show you what
they want to show you
at that point so what I'm saying in the
terms of content
it looks like being a rock star now
but also
perfect example how many fans does Danny
Duncan have
loyal fans a lot how many of those
people would be like I would love to do
that
they don't see how long it took
before they don't see the struggles and
the
probably going broke and poor and not
eating before that I'm sure he had a lot
of these people are only seeing the good
they're only seeing highlight reels of
people's accomplishments
so I think that's kind of
a damn
tainting people's brains a little
of course but the reason I want to talk
about it is because it's such a an
option yeah I mean look at I'm just two
years old you put a camera on her she
goes
make sure yeah she's talking to no one
there's no one else in there she knows
how to host a video knows how to intro a
video
that's crazy just naturally yeah that's
insane dude my little brother same thing
he's not
same thing all his homies doing little
intros or videos like dude I love it
it's cool because it makes you start to
think and it makes you be creative and
it makes you think I can do something
like this which is cool and I'm not
saying like earlier when I said oh you
only seeing the bad parts don't think
it's all good
I'm only saying like for a select when
it comes to everyone's gonna be a
content creator bro we need garbage men
still don't please just chill not
everyone needs to be on camera because
not everything you got to say
is you know notable and I'm saying that
as I'm saying some [__] I get that I
understand that but I'm saying when
you're starting out I I meet so many
content creators in the DMS they hit me
up for advice I talk to them but I'll go
I can go through someone's page and go
pack it up yeah don't do it you might
have a whole career like in that space
in a different position I don't want to
hear and it's kind of it kind of hurts
her feelings I'm like bro
all I did was see you flexing hella hard
with some like money impact but you just
told me you have no money you're trying
to make money
okay I was broke with packs and [__] but
I was selling those packs just trying to
get them done like dude and then I
stopped selling packs and I was just
always around weed
so I was really like dude
so it's kind of contradicting when I say
that because there was a couple times
I'm like let me see this take a picture
with it but I'll get rid of it for you
don't trip hey you want this pound like
there's a give and take of us in here
front and front right but I'm saying
like there's I can go through a page
like you really just want people to like
you and be famous and [__]
pack it up only weepy let's stay around
fools just do [__] to that fun it's part
of their life Goblin Eric or two we got
two people I can think of and we know
them very well but using examples
on and off camera they were both my
house the other day on and off camera
same [__] uh-huh same exact thing so
when I say like
I don't know what I'm trying to get to
like the genuine beat when you're
genuine the the kind of a unique
perspective whoa bro the content will
flow off people will see if you are
transparent
I mean what more could you ask for you
don't like it bro you know that's how I
feel that's how I feel if you don't like
it's totally cool and I think uh
like I said everyone wants to be a
YouTuber now right totally good that's
dope my advice to you do [__] you like
do not I met this one weed tuber guy
once I don't really [__] uh
and I'm like yo that's how as we're
talking about the videos and he's like
oh so how do you play videos like
um I don't know it's like I'll be
sitting there like do you'll be sick
this Do Fools know how to do this dabs
do you know how to do the whole process
but I'll make a video on this let me
sick huh I think it'll help or I'll be
like you don't be sick you know people
don't know how to do backflips I bet you
people be like oh and I always think of
what are the reactions of the comments
people are gonna go dude I needed this I
needed this step I've been trying to I'm
like don't trip it's free on the
internet now you can watch it that's why
I do it because I know that it'll help
because I've been there
so many people at the meet and greets
was the first one they said they say you
taught me how to roll a joint always in
the store tell me how to roll backwards
bro like [__] yeah always at the store
like thank you
like yeah oh yeah but no I was with a
YouTuber dude he goes I just go through
the most popular videos when I do weed
uh copy the title I'll do the video
[Music]
um
I didn't say anything in my hand I'm
like I don't like you anymore I don't
chill with the dude anymore I chill with
them like once and I'm like you are the
oh my God that was the first red flag is
like
visually plagiarizing and um that's the
number one thing like if you don't like
if you don't like genuinely makeup girls
what do they do in the day when their
makeup's not on I mean when their
cameras they're doing makeup still they
don't do it just like I'm gonna get
ready for my video I'm like no it's
their life how do you think she's so
good at it you can tell when someone's
friend you can tell when someone's just
there to be there to try to get a little
bit of shine so when it comes to content
I think it's do what you want Danny
Duncan
I don't think there's a structure there
I think he's just doing what his life
entails yeah why do people watch because
what I've just said ratchet man is on
tour with Danny Duncan right now he's in
Texas right now right he FaceTime me the
other night they're all at some place
and there was a bunch of fans and
they're sick to watch the show he always
says that to me drunk and [__]
and uh there's a reason people watching
Duncan you can see that that is genuine
there's a reason people watch people
because he could see it yes there's
trendy people and people watching just
because like oh crank this that's cool
but when it comes to content my advice
to you do stuff that you think is
awesome
first it doesn't have to be the whole
idea say the Vlog is like going to do
this this make sure your key point you
like it
that's it you're enthusiastic you're
enthusiastic because you wanted to do it
and like it people ask me all the time
you should go you know budget job but
they're like no because they'll show the
video that I don't want to do it why am
I doing this I don't want to be here I'm
an adult what I'm gonna do stuff that's
how I feel like I'm gonna do that I'm
like no jump out of a plane come on I'll
get views don't care
there's a million things we could do
there's a billion views a million things
I'm good so when it comes to that I
think it's just
50 50 though like you you could cater
like I said you can cater to your
audience but you have to be enthusiastic
and like what you're doing and then that
video can be Blended and you can that's
what that's like what ad reads are like
yo I like this I'll blend it into my
[__] yeah it's all good let's do it
that's like if you put it this way if
you feel a little bit corny probably
shouldn't do what you're doing
simple as that after one interview we're
halfway through it would it be weird if
I just left it was like five years ago I
was doing like I hate this Rick Ross I
am so cool I feel so corny here
I want to leave I'm not gonna say who or
where I was at but I don't know where
that episode is or that whoever if they
even have that anymore but I guarantee
you can see it on my face I couldn't
hide it I was sitting there like
worse yeah no no for sure I'm like I
feel rude not being stoked
overall
everything that we're talking about
across the board is that little
intuition that you got to get in tune
with and Trust
that I mean obvious situations like that
but there's a million little times we
always I mean how many times do I say
like if you're questioning something
I'll be like just trust your intuition
but you got to be really in tune with it
and trust it yeah the more experience
you get the stronger it is yes what's I
know I was just sitting here ranting but
I'm trying to get my point across it's
kind of hard to get the point across as
something so new [__] being a full-time
person that makes content is so new
like you're gonna say that for like the
past six years people can say that on
Earth history legitimate option right so
I'm trying to get it across the people
that people come up to me I would love
to do this I would love to do that
if you're saying you would love to do it
you're probably not going to do it go
[__] do it what is it what do you
what do you what's up
what do you waiting on you have a phone
you fill with your phone my first story
times are all on my phone in a grow
light I got the grow light from a friend
like you could you could do these things
if you just go for it and I guarantee
you that after that first video You're
Gonna know you know what I'm saying
you're gonna know like
I could see yeah do that that's that was
fun also you got to remember
you can pay someone's rent
show them God and they'll probably still
talk [__]
so when it comes to being a content
creator even if you're the most positive
dude and you like just helpful people
still call you piece of [__] and you're
gonna be tough so you know what I do I
go you're probably just having a bad day
if I've talked to 75 000 people that are
rude 74 000 of them have apologized at
the end
I just got with this morning it's like
bro what's going on are you okay
my brows is taken out of you I'm sorry I
was just pissed off like yeah I could
tell because I don't know you and you're
saying these things about me with that
what it is is I know myself well so when
people say things I'm like that's not
even legitimate
yeah he's kind of having a bad day but
you got to remember people that this is
the number one thing to remember people
that are rude to you online are sad in
person so being rude right back is not
gonna help if anything it's fueling them
to go see that's why people just don't
like me and there might be delusional
and think like yo I was not rude like
you called me a piece of [__] yeah
you're being rude why don't you say how
I felt like oh so you're you but your
thoughts were rude yeah some people
don't get it some people are weird just
remember as a content creator it comes
with a territory dude
um Amazon is the funniest nicest guy and
people hate on them all day why who
cares why do you even care talk about
all the other people that love them do
you love like it's it's easy to come if
there's a thousand good comments there's
one negative it's easy to point it out
because it's the only one but then again
it's who said it
if someone ruins 10 minutes of your day
are you gonna let him like destroy them
or was it if you have 100 eggs you drop
one or you're just gonna drop them all
because you dropped one
bastard it's like you have one comment
room like there's a thousand good ones
though yeah
what a good way to put it if you dropped
a nug you're gonna throw the zip no I
what are you gonna do you're gonna try
to salvage what's left same thing you're
gonna try to make good learn from
dropping that nog thank you Marty we're
just all these stupid analogies we have
guys sorry
what that's what I'm trying to get at
because that's a big thing people ask me
in the comments like I want to make
content but people are such things like
did they really matter no one that I've
ever met has ever come up to me and said
that what they said online anybody's
ever been rude has never walked up to me
and said rude comment
that's funny I'm not wishing it but I'm
not saying like I'm nervous about it man
when I first started rapping I would get
some crazy ass phone calls and
voicemails and [__] when I started
putting myself out there yeah why just
because I was putting more just because
I mean I think I mean everybody had my
number I was just a kid you know what I
mean like you knew were hitting you no
just a couple times I was getting you
know like I was
this is what we're talking about like
when you put yourself out there like
that especially like how I was in rap
all aggressive and [__] like you're
gonna get negative feedback just from
the world now every time you go out you
got to be ready for that I didn't want
to call you only right at First Once the
world got used to me it was all good but
I had a couple calls like threatening me
in chat
yeah
it was all good what yeah yo that song
although you should be wrapping it I'ma
kill you like what kind of [__] is
basically just like just like little
like I mean I remember how Eminem used
to have little threats on his voice and
what happened like probably once or
twice like barely ever but like dude
like rap my lyrics and then like set
some crazy [__] and hung up type of [__]
that that was kind of around the time
where I had some controversy yeah yeah
but I mean you got to be I mean music oh
I know a song they quoted
I know what you're talking about yeah
yeah
um so when it comes to that take it with
ease man like if someone screwed you in
public
it's rare but that used to scare me too
dude I have a fear of going to places I
don't like going to parties I don't like
doing events that aren't ours
this is why I'm gonna be brutally honest
and I guarantee people are gonna like
that's how I feel and I hope it helps
you I have a fear that people are going
to be rude and I'm gonna have to go to
jail for beating the [__] out of them I
don't like talking to new people because
I feel like yo I'm extremely polite I'm
very nice and if you do not reciprocate
that I'm gonna beat this [__] out of you
that's how I feel like I don't want to
be mean I have the fear that I'm gonna
be mean because someone's rude isn't
that stupid but unless it's a legitimate
the everywhere I go I don't like talking
to people in the elevators I'm like hey
how you doing
as somebody that talks to so many people
that's but what I see there's always a
Vibe of like
hey what's up but I you know what I'm
saying like when I I feel like when I'm
in public but I'm like I don't go to
nightclubs yeah I don't do that stuff I
don't go to bars and parties like
I'm too nice for that bro and I'm also a
dick if you're a dick to me so that's
how I feel like I don't ever like being
upset so I don't want to put myself in
positions to go get upset it's fair and
that I think this is called like anxiety
but once I'm there like bro I'll talk to
every single one of you in this room I
don't give a [__] it's fine I'll tell
you a story I don't care but I have that
anxiety and I know other people feel
that too so online I don't because I
can't punch you in the face
it's fair
does that make sense like when we ever
do live shows like don't
be a heckler
don't
just don't do it
I'll pay one of my friends and knock you
asleep like yo I'll be on stage you
smack him like you're an audience member
that got pissed and I'll bail you out
but no for real I'm not gonna do that
but that's a pretty good little Melody
so that's a pretty good little thing
like yo so I'll bail you out if anybody
starts talking a circle the room and
punch him in the back we'll be all good
I'm not gonna do that but this is
evidence that ever happens I'm not
really going to do that but hey don't be
a day things you got to think about yeah
but online like dude that's the number
one thing people are rude to you these
nothing's gonna happen it's fine they're
in person most those people aren't going
to do nothing but when it comes to
content creation that's the number one
thing people ask like how do you deal
with the people every single time they
ask that's one of the first questions
they ask how do you deal with people
being rude how do you deal with people
owning up to it and kind of like
standing on whatever if they're if it's
oh yeah if it's online it's like yeah
it's hot like you don't have to engage
with a negative I usually 99 of the time
I just
I don't got time for this because block
like I don't care enough to rebuttal it
I've seen people be way too proud to
acknowledge real [__] being said to them
by the fans and not take them down oh no
like I said if it's if I'm like oh
there's some there's some weight to that
that's true but then again every time
that happens I go
hmm good feedback fool I didn't even
thought about that fair point you're
right Fair Point fool you're right I've
responded to fools being dicks like
you're right also you could have worded
that nicer yeah I say that all the time
there's a way to say it I always say
that to fools it was just a joke dog I
get that all the time it was just a joke
was it really but uh you guys got to
remember when you come to creating
content just make stuff you like make
stuff that's fun and don't think about
trying to make money off it if money
comes from you making content you're
crushing it and if it comes with it
that's great if you need to make money
out of content maybe you know start
thinking other things push trees I made
push trees I was like you know this can
puddle the content I don't ever have to
make money on this content hell yeah and
that's the only thing that let it happen
I'm sure like look at Logan Paul and
Prime and all this [__] dude they're all
competing with Gatorade and Powerade but
look what comes off of that it doesn't
have to be Logan Paul drink yeah it's
something else push trees does not say
dope Zola Prime does not say Logan Paul
there's a reason why you have to
separate yourself and make something
bigger than yourself when it comes to
the products but like so once again back
to the to the content consistency is my
last thing you have to be on it like we
said if Simpsons doesn't come out every
Sunday you'd be pissed sitting there
going you let me down I don't trust next
week is it gonna happen again the
consistency not saying you have to post
every day the same week or every week
the same day but being consistent being
consistent with your fans and I got to
be honest just caring dude you give a
[__] big time I give a [__] yeah it's
really what counts it's like working out
you know like
why it's like you can gain that momentum
but as soon as you stop you just stop
it's the worst it steps backwards very
quickly I don't know man that's why
we're in the chat that's why we put this
episode out a little later because we
were doing the uh
live chat sometimes at that time yeah
so that's really it guys I actually give
it a [__]
that's it don't be nice on camera and
dissing fans not taking the picture when
there's no cat you know what I mean
there's there's levels to being a piece
of [__] and I think if you start with
any level you're not gonna make it
unless you're an absolute Superstar
that's allowed to be a piece of [__]
because you've just got so big-headed so
I always think of it like Takashi or
some [__] last thing
last part of this like having fans and
stuff that's it's fun like when we go to
the meet and greets my yo this is the
cool I only feel like
thank you holy [__] I always you know as
you always think back like damn Fool's
yourself make fun of my ass I always
think like I used to get pregnant so I
always think like thanks guys this is
sick but some people like don't let it
get to your head like bro what are you
talking about this is stupid that's the
same hi
what's up guys same [__] yeah but now I
started thinking I said the other day I
just want to bring this up real quick
could you imagine
being 22 and your rap career took off
right
you're doing nowadays 10 billion streams
a month the biggest ever right
you go into shows
you're selling out arenas
and you could do the Michael Jackson
where you just look
people are like screaming and passing
out
I think that might have to change your
brain chemistry a little definitely I
think it does you're not the same person
a little bit so give Kanye West a little
bit of break I think he went crazy yeah
I think his brainwick snap you can't
handle this over overload overload stay
wild [__] I think his brain went I'm
gone I'm out you're too big bro you're
too big of a star because there's
sometimes I see these concerts are a bad
bunny dude
come on bro what is that feeling of
having hundreds of thousands of fools in
front of you just waiting for you to go
what's up that's pretty wild I'm sure it
messes with your brain a little but if
you can keep that on I think it's like
the coolest [__] then you get Adam
Sandler's
so that's what I was thinking because
remember I told you I had that dude I
told Marty like a year and a half ago I
had a weird ass dream I was walking
through the airport remember did I tell
you remember this yeah I was walking
through the airport and I saw this dude
with a sign I'm like
what the hell
and I look at the security with me like
why the [__] it's just cute what did I
do and I look back and there's like 500
fools with like our gear and signs
rushing me at the airport and then the
security pushes me into some room like
I just see something
I was like that was the craziest [__]
that's ever happened that was the
weirdest feeling ever all I thought was
like
yeah I want to say hi to fools what are
you doing and then I thought
that was the weirdest feeling ever and
that and that's why I started thinking
something something has to happen with
like that brain chemistry [__] so I
don't know how he got into this but I
think it has to check I was thinking the
Rolling Stones earlier it's like Mick
Jagger must be yeah a temperature for a
rock star God for 50 years plus if they
evaluated his worrying it's got to be
it's got to be like the waves it has to
change something had to have had his ego
part of his brain must have like like
the Grinch when it gets big that's high
yeah what are we talking about you want
to tell the people about the uh the
little event you got going on
it's going down all right it's finally
going down you guys been asking for a
very long time
it's not like I can just go you know
what make it happen let me text these
fools to invite me you guys be like yo
smoke off with whiz you should smoke off
a snoop like
yeah that'd be that'd be fun of course
of course you should do that you got
like a way to make it happen if not just
I'm Gonna Keep you know editing
yeah but people say like I can do it
yeah is it every two seconds is this
Snoop yeah no if it's not the Snoop Dogg
episode then why am I watching
you're saying basically you should just
go watch Snoop Dogg's show yeah
so people always say that to us so
anyway shout out to DJ afterthought my
friend Ryan
wisdom Friends Wiz and friends is
something they do they live stream with
new Ty Dolla Sign a couple other fools
and uh
they do wizard friends they get they've
read some Mansion they get Halloween
they smoke it out play video games and
twitch stream the whole thing so this
year these fools ask for me to
personally be there
thank you very much finally
finally gonna happen crazy so I have a
little plan of what I'm gonna do
wasn't Snoop
[__] up right they smoke they smoke
power smoking or something
I'm Gonna Roll through with with stuff
that like
you can't forget
do you already know or is it still open
on it I already know what I'm gonna do
I guess I could no I don't want to say
it because then no I'm not going to say
it I'm gonna get these fools so
what would you say that ungodly
aggressively prolifically High I'm gonna
get these fools so high under 10 minutes
that it's that I hope they're like bro
we gotta cut the stream short my I'm so
happy to hear that that's what I want to
hear I want these fools to go home and
go who was that brown kid who's that kid
that they invited over their toilet I
want them to be so [__] gone
you've been challenged so many times
throughout the years oh there's a big
Jake from Fresno dad and Maniac from La
uh Johan Johan from Seattle two other
dudes that I don't remember their names
they're the only people I've ever seen
in my life that went I don't want to
smoke with you I don't want to smoke
like that I don't want to be part of
this that's disgusting
no that's like chugging fifths the way
they smoke I can't take bong rips like
that for Big Jake I can't I can't take
that as I damn it maniac my body will
not allow me to smoke like that
possibility it looks like when Kirby
from Pokemon or is it was not Pokemon
what's that real no what's that no
what's the other one that no it is Kirby
that goes
it blows and Smash Brothers or is it a
Pokemon that blows up with air pretty
sure it's Kirby anyway uh oh no he
inhales Kirby vacuum burnt that's how
they smoke
I've seen this man take a five gram dab
in one dab like nothing happened I
watched it he's not
puffing it nah he's ripping it
ripping it snakes
while two fools are hitting it with a
torch to keep it going disgusting
I have one of his dads on video the LA
uh Black Market Vlog Los Angeles Black
Market Vlog on the dopasiola channel
That Guy dabbing that snake that's one
of the time that scene of dabbing I
recorded it I think Jay guys went live
with him dude from
Fresno area he's like six six he takes
Bob ribs bigger than this whole table
like it's just it's disgusting I watched
it put like a four grand Bowl packet
full just rip it Audrey the giant of
weed what do they normally do on this
stream no it wasn't a stream no I'm
saying listen friends they just could
hide and play and play video games it's
like a party it's like like a party with
a bunch of celebrity fools gotcha and
I'm gonna come through and get them all
wrecked and then I'm just gonna go home
well that's how it's gonna end let's go
so shout out to Ryan DJ afterthought for
the invite shout out to wizard snooper
finally
thanks they personally asked like yo
bring this full like yeah
yeah I can't wait I'm gonna come through
with like a goodie bag but yo for later
once you're at home eat that [__] smoke
that [__] slight that right now like
that right now oh
I've been waiting for this moment little
do they know little do they know
just live stream so
are you bringing a cameraman you're
gonna have one of the yeah oh the dope
is a sponsoring it that's the other
thing yeah a couple days later but
they're like yo we're looking for
sponsors you know any Wii companies go
how about we just sponsor it so it's us
and liquid death they're gonna sponsor
it oh sick so yeah we're filming it they
asked me yeah come bring your camera out
there crazy I'm excited so yeah guys
finally gonna happen this Wiz and and
Snoop smoke out then again what if it's
such a big part of that I don't even see
these fools we're all just smoking and
hanging I don't know I also knows I'm
I'm coming prepared
that's all that matters I was there for
the test I showed up that's all I don't
know it's not a competition
just in case it turns in but I also want
them to go who is that why what's
happening bringing the rig bringing the
bomb
bringing a lot of stuff
I'm very excited I think I'm gonna I
think John's gonna come with me because
the dopest I think I'm gonna have him
help me with like all this this is
coming out one
the 30th isn't Friends remember shows
live it's just live wow yeah but they'll
be able to go on Twitch get clips and
I'm gonna film
um I'll tell you the names after there's
a lot of fools there so I don't know if
we're gonna film everything but
we'll see but yeah finally all right
it's gonna happen guys I'm excited
yeah no we got a couple big episodes
coming up we got Professor coming up
I think the day he gets his cast off
he's coming in yes oh nle Choppa is
rescheduled
for everybody keeps asking rescheduled
don't know when but when we get it we'll
get it all right probably next month
let's just commence call March done
there's only a couple days left of March
let's just say April all right
um huh does he write yeah I know what
does he race the 27th yeah 29th
that's 27.
but you already know you guys a Friday
oh thank God
okay me Rosie started looking at wedding
venues we have a 20.
right but we're okay nice okay but you
know dizzy right right yeah he's awesome
go to the I could tell you needed it
music video by Dizzy Wright you might
see this high ass full spoken to QP I
was smoking a QB I rolled over all the
uh my homies roll the joints for that
one that picture be on the History
Channel
with those Choice wear the push tree
[__] with the joy of my mouth that's
from that music video shoot they used it
on the History Channel
and uh yeah Disney's awesome I've been
to his house that's the first person I
ever saw that was not older with a house
like that I went to his gated ass
community
because he lives in Vegas went over
there chilled with him but I remember
walking it like
prices your house
it's just like a it's a really nice out
but like I don't I don't know people
that have houses I don't I come from
Merced I still lived in Merced when I
went there it was a long time no I
wasn't L.A but yeah I went to his house
we chilled we smoked uh which has been
his music videos I invited him a hell of
cannabis cups
I just haven't seen him in like four or
five years man nice everything is a long
time he was perfect cool
such a chill dude like a genuinely nice
dude he's the one that got me on
Hennessy okay that's why I started
drinking Hennessy because it's dizzy
right wow I forgot
I went to I went to his studio with my
mom's son was there and we were taking
dabs I'm like who is this funny ass
blonde dude with a piercing and I just
thought he was cool we were smoking and
drinking and then after they're like oh
that's mine so I'm like I don't know
what it is and I realized like oh okay
he's an artist that I listened and saw
him like oh this was hard and that was
anyway they were they were recording the
Floyd Money maywether song that's what
they were doing that night they were
recording Disney song and he was like
previewing it we're all drinking and we
were drinking Hennessy and I never
really drank Hennessy and they were
chasing with a little bit of apple juice
like that and that's where I got apple
juice Tech from that everybody was like
why do you drink apple juice and
Hennessy there's a part on Snapchat
where for like four years but like damn
that's full of apple juice because dizzy
right he's the reason why and uh wow
again the best it was an exhibits uh old
studio and I walked in and saw an
exhibit [__] like wow and then a couple
years later I went to the same place
right next door for some weed [__] I
remember thinking like I've been to the
store all right scan my Jimmy Neutron oh
yeah dizzy right and then yeah to a
small world small world how everything
works yeah Disney rice dude yeah isn't
that crazy you ever hear of people
drinking pickle juice as a chicken yeah
they're picklebacks
it's the best dude but yeah he's the one
that introduced me to Hennessy I forgot
about that I'm gonna I don't even know
if he drinks anymore but that fool was
like vegan before I ever even heard
vegan I remember
if I remember right
sorry I just mixed him up he went vegan
a little after this guy sorry the person
I'm thinking about is the one that
measured but anyway this is awesome dude
I'm excited and we got the professor
coming the second he says I'm across him
I'm put the ball underneath the chair
and I'm gonna be like vulnerable now
you're sitting could you imagine off in
that catching get out of here bro I
can't wait for that I stick the Nerf nut
over his head right here
just ruin our relationship for the
professor forever just for the best clip
of all time no I don't think we're gonna
go that route but I would love to we'll
protect the professor yeah we'll protect
it it has a messed up foot I just got my
Sports Illustrated that's what I'm
saying he's vulnerable no I wanted to
see uh
remember I was like yo can we just do
like 10 seconds can I try to cross you
and you just try to cross me and then he
broke his foot he broke his foot
I can't cross a broke foot Professor
then it's not real I'm not going to
cross him anyway but the fact that I'm
like you got it that was when he had a
broken foot Tom is like oh I'll never
live it down bro in your own mind my own
mind like did I really get the professor
or did I
not sure next there you go better luck
next year there we go guys we're we're
just ranting over here we're just
talking but this has been an episode
go check out the Russell episode YouTube
we uploaded it twice a couple of times
and we photoshopped my weed shirt out
because we're like is it the shirt
so ridiculous we Photoshop it in the
thumbnail it's like dude why did you age
restrict
La Russell what did we talk about that
was it was all motivational positive
entrepreneurial
music
I don't know but YouTube really did not
like the Little Wrestlers they just
shunned it anyway go watch the little
Russell episode that guy is awesome one
of our best episodes I thought he was
great yeah I thought it was a great
episode
um Dj drama episode dropped a couple
hours the chills watching the back it
was so sick it was epic and she's dope
as hell he's nice dude
hit us up after the show he was very
chill dude I like him
um
yeah that was it guys that's all I
really got to say Marty what about you
thank your eyes I'm feeling great I'm
inspired by Rosie and Adam Miller and
everybody they wanted to have a marathon
Marathon I'm about to turn up my whole
routine butts yeah it's May 7th it's
26th also yeah so yeah I'm about to I
put up a post on Instagram about losing
a bunch of weight and everybody asked me
how I did it so I'm gonna make a little
video on YouTube about my routine but
I'm flip-flopping my routine around up
until the marathon now to just like
really run more I need to get my miles
in nice so that's Rosie dude she has a
little routine down there she has like a
certain Miles She runs every week and
whatnot yeah which is a trip I saw a 90
year old dude across the Finish Line
yesterday it was nice and a big ass
Mexican food was big as a van cross the
finish line I was like wow yeah I'm lazy
that's all I thought I was like you got
this so far
26 miles this giant man red are you
kidding me finished before Rosie did I
was waiting for Rosie like I remember I
saw him like jail
Jesus Christ but yeah dude this shows do
you want to do something you can do it
don't say I want to do it just go do it
all right the the moral of this episode
free game I hope you absorbed all of
this I hope if you have any of these
interests
now you can go just go to LegalZoom it's
the easiest thing we're not plugged by
them she illegally with sponsorship
um just go do it it's the easiest thing
go watch uh how to start a clothing
company on the adventures YOLO Channel
it helps go watch any of Marty's
episodes on his Marty made it YouTube if
you're into anything
Tech
I guess you would say because you talk
about your Client List how you built
your Client List these are very
important things that people are never
going to tell you that's how I feel
about all this like they're never going
to tell you that don't they teach
classes for that they're not they're not
they're gonna make you sick pay for a
course to get this and it's for free on
the YouTube channel all you do is it
would be sick if you like press like
thank you so much for all I've gotten so
many amazing comments on my YouTube it's
just like this channel like I really I
really I think about it all the time
really helps me out what's the one you
put out
the one is like a story time
oh how I get the coolest jobs in the
world how I get the coolest jobs in the
world please go watch that Marty did
basically a story time with overlays but
the overlays made me call him after
GoPro we need more overlays and story
time this is how I would like to see
Story Time more overlays like it was so
sick go watch that one go watch that how
I get the how I get the coolest job in
the world I love it it's so dope just go
watch like 25 minutes I watched the
whole thing just stuck and it was so and
I knew all of it I already knew every
one of those pieces and I'm sitting
there so that's when I know like oh this
is good I'll just sit there and space
out like when I'm editing I keep
watching stuff or I used to like oh this
is a cool video I just got stuck that's
awesome that's when you know like oh
hell yeah so go watch Dude Marty's
pumping out content same with us we're
always pumping out content doing new
stuff
that's it push trees wait for 420 wait
for the 420 drop it's gonna be so dope
above and beyond that we're going to be
doing a lot more stuff with push trees
like I don't want to talk about it yet
but we plan some things that are amazing
collaborations coming this year licensed
collaborations coming this year
um
it looks it looks nice with the designer
we were just saying let's just say that
the push trees pairs nicely with all the
designer Brands I
this is the next step we're gonna have a
little level I'll just leave with this
like you were saying earlier what about
the price points
there's post trees and maybe we drop
collections that you're like problem
this is so expensive Mike
yeah it's kind of expensive it was very
expensive to make also or that was Gucci
That would be fourteen hundred dollars
I'm not charging you fourteen hundred
dollars but I'm giving you this I mean
this will use
run v-load kind of says high-end
streetwear better than anything can say
hi in streetwear and that's where we
need to be we need to be at the level
like you shouldn't be on Rodeo but you
shouldn't be on Fairfax like you're
you're like in the little middle term
like yeah no some of our drops are so
sick they come with a box and a tie
where we're going full Louis Vuitton
style where you get your stuff on Rat
Pack like we're
I was so excited to be proud of myself
on that level
even if even if it costs fifty dollars
to make we charge 55 as long as you go
oh [__] I just want the reaction this
fool just leveled this [__] up you've
gone so deep into designer stuff since
the last push through your drops like
that's why I personally and that's why I
look at it like
a [__] I can do that for push trees I
know it'd be kind of expensive but I bet
you people would like it there's no
Stoner gear out there that you can wear
not to the Cannabis Cup if you want to
wear some stick [__] like yeah that's
that's a weed Bradley is it damn that's
nice and uh that's where we're headed
I'm very excited super stoked for all
these new things the rehab shop is
we're going to start doing more stuff
we're getting designers to ship at wow
it's doing so good the rehabs the rehab
store
the rehabstore.com is the video is crazy
unbelievable oh yeah the new videos
coming out go watch on dopashop.com I
mean go watch on dopa's Yola Channel
let me just talk about the rehab push
trees weed that's coming out I found an
OG for the genetics
and if we run this for push trees I will
say it's the best
OG in the America legal Market
Mission like a politician that OG was so
fire the one in the video
wow
that was the top three oh geez I ever
smoked wow all right it birds so good
and it left tingles right here under the
push trees brand now yeah
I don't even know what to call a
Straight Like That
if I could smoke one stream in my life
forever it'd be that one it was the
perfect weed forever OG oh I loved it
dude anyway sorry I'm ranting here now
but I'm finally excited again like I was
going through the motions for a while
just trying to get things done because I
was so stressed out like time time I
don't have this oh this business is here
and now I'm more like oh my God I can't
wait to crush
each of these things and delegate things
for each person so every brand has its
own thing
it's working everybody has some role now
like I'm not the only person doing [__]
now so it's I mean Rosie too but yeah
I'm excited push trees coming Marty's uh
YouTube's there
I'm uh I'm waiting two more days on this
damn car then I'm I'm not buying it
sorry I'll just update you guys asked me
every five seconds I don't know where
the car is at this guy's pissing me off
today's Monday it's by Wednesday he
doesn't have an answer for me I'm gonna
tell him to consume a dick through his
mouth but I'm leaving bro I already know
what I'm gonna go get it's gonna be
piece of [__] but I better go do it
because I'm gonna do it we'll see Are
You Gonna Keep that a mystery
oh there's like a Rolls-Royce Royce uh
ghost
it's so nice at this there's a there's a
there's this wraith I saw I went to
Rolls-Royce the other day because I was
just like
what does these look like in person John
but I want to see them like on the
showroom floor it took like 40 minutes
for somebody to try to help me I was
wearing Vans and [__] but I don't give a
[__] well I want to buy your cards just
don't judge me on my shoes I had to go
like yo could you possibly help me like
look at some cars and they're like yeah
damn you guys are jerks and then the guy
that helped me was super nice I'm like
bro
I might just buy this card you guys are
like can I can you help me please that's
how I felt like jail dude that's they
pulled on me at Mercedes this for 20
minutes I'm asking five people for help
and they kept blowing me off and blowing
me and then the guy that was super nice
we bought the car right then and there
from him people are dicks bro what's up
I don't I hate people people are so rude
for no reason anyway
I'll wait until Wednesday
next episode well no next episode we'll
know I hope to God the car comes in I
don't want to buy Rolls-Royce it's just
expensive as hell but I've been thinking
about like it's a monthly payment it
adds this much to the car payment I
already have
doable it's not I know those cars are
expensive but it's not you're not buying
it all away at once and when it comes to
business and this that's why learning
and watching this episode will help for
tax purposes
I've only drive it to the podcast to the
warehouse maybe to get food like I don't
do [__] I'm always busy that's a company
car every time you leave the house it's
business every time unless me and Rosie
go to the movies or I go to John's a
block and a half away to go get high
that's it
so business expense all those miles the
gas the insurance just remember that
that's a reason all right yeah see I
just don't want to get the car because I
feel kind of like a piece of [__] like
damn
what are you doing but at the same time
it's like that's a nice house corner
like your neighbors got one with them
all three of my neighbors
there's a ghost and there's a wraith
there's a there's a there's a there's a
Cullen and I'm looking I'm like wow
those are nice I don't have a car I've
been thinking out there
I'm like damn these are nice cars
what do you guys do and I'm like you
live here like yes it just it blows my
mind every time I was talking to the
last thing before we go this guy was
telling me taking the trash I paid this
dude to take all these boxes from moving
the first thing what the [__] do you do
I'm gonna talk with him and then like
from the same area and I was explaining
like dude we're like the same [__]
person it is so weird I I just do moving
and [__] and it's like
finally man it took a while but finally
I'm probably the guy I'm like what do
you do like I used to ask everybody what
do you do every single time it's like
yes uh podcast production and then I
just like all right bye as I tell
everybody but dude if I don't know it
just feels weird it's cool but it feels
weird
um
it's important to recognize that though
I felt it the other day I was like wow
finally sick
but it's cool I don't give a [__] but
it's fun it's been fun it's just bigger
place to smoke weed at so I see the
living room man's like damn house yeah
it's just everything I'm like can I box
it can I hot box it it's sick hop off
the [__] out of the van let's have OG
and Mindy oh
so that was last night that's how high I
was I was like was it last night yes I
saw you do the math on that but do the
math on that math
[Laughter]
look like
they're not fat here we go all right
let's get out of here we're just gonna
be ranting and ransing and Ransom guys
thank you for being here me and Mark are
just talking about stuff
uh yeah ketchup episodes solo episodes
teachers out of the room my favorite
part I'm Carlos
Marty's pool's almost done
looks like a real Resort out there it's
getting there a lot of things coming so
the next solo episode I'll hopefully
have a car Marty will have a pool
and hopefully
push trees up and running I just want to
see people's reactions I just want to
see people be Juiced about it that's all
I care about they're going to be so
excited to see a new job and the job I
showed you I was excited yeah dude I'm
very stoked um
thank you guys thank you for being here
and this should have been 25 minutes ago
but it's you know we're here thank you
guys so much for being here Marty his
YouTube channel Marty made it Instagram
Marty made it Twitter Marty made it
right yeah my Instagram dope with
periods in between
on YouTube why don't I ever think about
that I got the name yeah I don't have to
do like a variation yeah topazole on
YouTube and then Twitter topaz yellow
with underscores and [__] it's too much
it's like 500 scores guys thank you so
much for being here uh this has just
been like a fun episode this is dope I
hope it helped
that's really it drop a comment let us
know I hope it helps man if you're in
the chat still thank you and if you're
still in the chat drop a like I hope you
guys are still chilling I know I'm in my
house right now doing the chat we we're
in the chat everybody thinks we like pay
somebody to do it or it's a pot what
Bots [__] like I do all the time
nobody's setting up a butt suck my dick
or something like oh what are you doing
like yeah that's us
smell like a talk part of Citizen style
come on guys uh thank you so much for
being here follow all Marty [__] follow
my stuff that'd be sick the podcast a
YouTube channel thank you so much for
hanging out watching it Instagram on the
podcast dope as usual podcast we just
hit a hundred thousand today we hit 250
000 on YouTube guys we had a quarter
mill on YouTube today
thank you guys that's pretty quick
that's pretty wild if you think about it
it really is all the people coming like
dude you only have a quarter mill on
YouTube like that's not that much for a
big pot right for a podcast that has
people on it it's like damn we're we're
getting there man one day it's gonna say
1 million and we're gonna get the plaque
for it too clean I'm excited thank you
guys so much for being here making it
possible thank you guys appreciate you
and I think that's it let me get out of
here from Marty and I this has been the
dope's usual podcast we were here to
talk about live drugs problem
accomplishments and a bunch of random
ass [__] and that was today thank you
for being here guys until next time I'm
dopa Zola have a dope ass day
[Music]
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie